a Texas house committee has voted to
advance a bill that would raise the
legal age to buy an AR style weapon from
18 to 21. the eight eyes five names and
zero president
[Applause]
you hear those cheers there some came
from parents who lost their everything
their children in Uvaldi last year those
parents had protested peacefully in the
capital before that vote among other
things the bill would also make it
illegal to sell a gun to someone under
the influence and two Republicans joined
Democrats in passing the measure was
bipartisan however the GOP majority in
the state house and Governor Greg Abbott
are not expected to support the
legislation